Rachel yes sure I'm Greg gray I'm the
right so welcome to the channel people
listen we're gonna do a try not to laugh
challenge okay I've never done this
before I've never done a try not to
laugh challenge and I've always wondered
how I would do this comes from a channel
called ninja Panda - okay I like the
name Avengers infinity war unnecessary
seem like an unnecessary yeah one of my
favorites ever have you seen the one
with the count from Sesame Street
no oh yeah no it's great
one two three four one four well let's
try this out with infinity war people
okay one no laughing you have had the
privilege
of me by the great time
so you woke up and naturally we were yes
I did dream about it was so real thank
you Tony Stark I'm dr. Stephen strange I
said all right
the house is covered it doesn't matter
we're not made of tiny metal fiber stop
massaging is Gamora this is a daughter
of Thanos your father brother Oh
stepfather technically I'm performing
for all the guide you told me that I had
a sister returned home okay
is it the stone again its feet what does
it say we don't want to oh we will
you'll never get the chance again Thanos
gets me
I want you to promise me what if you
want to stand in our way
[Laughter]
Thanos has the biggest in the universe
we have to destroy it now yeah great I
want to the stone I don't even mean now
seriously don't know how you figure into
that you should've ducked out when I
told you to I tried to do you refuse
unlike everyone else in your life that
works in I'm Peter by the way dr.
strange
oh no names um I'm spider-man then it's
you who doesn't understand that fairness
has been inside Mike for six years
yeah but I mean this Thanos were talking
about he's the toughest there is well
he's never me twice property else it'd
be safe I swear to you I'm gonna freeze
[Music]
right you can't
who are you your other ones Thor told us
about you Thor yeah tall guy not that
good look before me a king's weapon
meant to be the greatest denars guard
they have a name
like resetting for that one was every
time was like oh god I really are dr.
strange soda when Captain America came
in and I don't know exactly said but it
was just it was just so deadpan and
looked so hot and was like cuz even they
Captain American one you could see
coming I think the best edited one was
when Tony Stark and dr. strange seemed
like they were arguing about each other
they're like you danos he was like yeah
I was like no sorry I had totally
totally understandable man some fellow
tempers sometimes really like this is
sounding like some type of assault but
the context are using like it seems like
a lot of you guys I know without wanting
to be war story into people who are each
other again and getting revenge like
make it a story new Japan great job one
is that it man it was a really hard try
not to laugh for sure sometimes he's
trying to laugh him like one or two
might get me with that that one was like
I screw it okay I think I got this but
then like something unexpected happen
yeah okay I get the joke because there's
just everything that wasn't wonderfully
edited ninja panda - congrats on the
success of this video man it's doing
well right now and I'm happy for you
well you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
BALCO subscribe button suck and I said
sucking you stick your tongue out trying
not to have the woman on this channel
get sexualized and you're ruining that
check out our reactions reviews thanks
for
[Music]